[Music]
there's no other climate quite as
inhospitable as the arctic
in the extreme north there are no trees
just sea snow and ice in this frozen
landscape the inuit people have made
their home it's a difficult life to be
sure but one they're remarkably well
adapted to to the inuit religion and
survival are intertwined failure to
follow the correct hunting rituals could
threaten the survival of your entire
tribe upset the mother of the sea sedna
and she'll withhold the ocean's seals in
her tangled hair starving you of your
primary food source dare to hunt alone
and you could risk being abducted by the
naught the monster seagull of the skies
so enter igloo and rustle up some muktuk
it's time to introduce you to inuit
mythology and the folklore of the arctic
[Music]
the inuit have historically lived
entirely above the arctic circle on the
northern seas and islands of greenland
canada alaska and parts of siberia
you're probably aware that the term
eskimo is a bit outdated it's believed
to translate to one who eats raw flesh
in algonquin understandably they prefer
to be known as inuit which simply means
people although humans have lived there
for many thousands of years the inuit
are the latest in a long line of people
groups to call the arctic their home is
believed that by the year 1100 the inuit
had replaced the previous people group
known as the dorset culture this
population shift is recorded in some
myths where the inuit speak of fierce
battles against ancestral giants known
as the tunit the first contact the inuit
had with the outside world may have been
in the viking era the icelandic
chronicle vinland saga tells the story
of eric the red's voyage to greenland it
describes how the viking explorers
encountered a strange people called the
skrelinger the skrelinger believed to be
the native inuit are depicted as being
wild and savage and were known to raid
early viking settlements in the new
world in the 1960s archaeologists found
the remains of a viking colony in
northern canada on the large island that
is coincidentally named newfoundland the
settlement however was long abandoned
the skrelinger may have chased them away
within the following centuries waves of
europeans began to settle the americas
the inuit shared a fate that many
indigenous people did to the south their
population was introduced to new
diseases that they had no natural
immunity to and survivors were forcibly
converted to christianity however
because the arctic climate is so
treacherous settlers were largely unable
to build permanent residences so far up
north the inuit already being well
adapted to these frosty conditions were
largely left alone in their ancestral
homelands as a result the beliefs
traditions and myths of the inuit have
largely survived into the modern day
before we turn onto the mythology itself
it's important to note that inuit is a
blanket term that covers a wide range of
people culture and language remember
we're talking about a massive area of
land stretching about 5000 kilometers
with such a diversity it's impossible to
talk about a unified mythology that
applies to all as we explore the
mythology of the inuit people just keep
in mind that we're drawing on a diverse
range of traditions
a key belief across inuit mythology is
that everything on earth has a life
force the word for this is inua
literally translating to person
every human has an innua but so too do
walruses whales and polar bears in this
way animals are simply different types
of people humans do not rule over the
natural world instead they exist as
equals to it when hunters catch and kill
an animal they're quite literally
killing another person therefore the
proper respect must be displayed and
there are rituals and traditions that
must be adhered to for example when a
hunter kills a polar bear it's important
to hang its skin up for a number of days
for other inuit people hunters must
place its severed head in the direction
of the body if the correct practices are
followed the inui of the polar bear will
be born into another animal or human
similar to reincarnation if any of these
rituals are not followed or done so
incorrectly it's believed that the inuit
of the animal will become angry and
reappear as a demon these demons could
cause you all kinds of trouble from the
relatively minor like bad luck to the
more life-ending like unsuccessful hunts
and blizzards it's therefore essential
to follow all the rituals and traditions
failing to do so may threaten your very
survival
the closest thing to a god or goddess in
inuit folklore are the number of nature
spirits and mythological figures perhaps
the most famous of these is the mother
of the sea known to many as sedna sedna
has a very dark origin story and there
are plenty of variations to it but they
tend to go something a bit like this
sedna was the daughter of the chief she
was the most beautiful woman in all the
tribe her hair was the longest as well
as the darkest so much so her father
attempted to marry her into the families
of powerful tribes sedna did not like
this and was not happy with any of the
men her father picked out for her in
protest she mocked her father by getting
married to a dog outraged and disgusted
sedna's father forced her into his kayak
and paddled out to sea from there he
threw her overboard into the icy water
she desperately attempted to climb back
on board but her father grabbed his
knife and sliced off her fingers her
severed digits became the first seals
unable to swim sedna sank to the bottom
of the sea and was transformed into a
vengeful sea spirit nowadays she prefers
the company of animals instead of humans
and is the guardian of marine life many
of whom enjoy nesting in her long hair
if humans fail to pay respect to the
animals that they catch sedna will
tangle them up in her hair in these
times of crisis a tribe shaman called an
angakuk will enter a trance and visit
her in their dreams apologizing
profusely to her on behalf of the tribe
and combing her hair to release the
animals
the myth of sedna underscores how
important it is to follow the many
rituals and superstitions because crops
don't grow in the arctic an inuit's diet
will consist largely of meats and animal
fats predominantly from whales and seals
if you upset sedna she'll likely drive
you and your tribe to starvation on a
less grim note in 2003 astronomers
discovered a large planet-like object
out in the cold fringes of our solar
system they decided to name it sedna in
honour of a frosty inuit spirit
[Music]
first up is the kalupalit these are half
women half scaly fish monsters that live
close by the shores they spend their
days waiting for children to stray away
from their families legend has it that
when they find a straight child they
drag it down into the icy depths and
devour them in underwater caves
you can see how this kalupulit story has
a practical purpose in daily life it's a
convenient and effective way to keep
children close by and away from the
ocean and thin ice there's also the now
jacuzzi look the so-called monster
seagull it flies about the arctic skies
looking for humans when it finds them it
swoops down catching them in its beak
and carrying them up into the air when
it reaches a high enough altitude it
will drop them down so they land on the
rocks below real seagulls do this with
crabs but this happens on a much larger
scale and finally we have the adlet the
dog people they are said to live in
tribes in northern greenland and are
known to attack humans that get too
close they'll spare the sled dogs
however and will even adopt them into
their tribe
soon it is said that the dogs will
transform into more adlets
the folklore of the arctic is immensely
practical focused on survival more than
theology or dogma there are plenty more
strange myths practices and traditions
that characterize inuit mythology so
i've included links down below if you
wish to do some further reading we'll
leave the mythology and folklore of the
arctic for now but i want to turn the
question on to you the viewer what
obscure mythology do you want to see me
cover next let me know the overlooked
and underrated mythologies and belief
systems that interest you
who knows i might cover it in a future
video
hey thanks for watching this video i
really hope you enjoyed this one if
you'd like to see more why not subscribe
a like and a comment also go a really
long way
anyway i look forward to seeing you next
time goodbye